the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we would like to begin our
study of calculus of several real
variables and as I mentioned in our last
lecture I would like to begin it from
the traditional point of view and I
guess I'd like to make a little bit of a
short speech even before we begin that
there may be a little bit of danger than
the way I've been emphasizing the modern
approach to mathematics that one may
actually believe that there's the
traditional approach to mathematics left
very very much to be desired
the answer is it didn't really that the
role of logic in good traditional
mathematics was about the same as it is
in good modern mathematics that in fact
if we define new mathematics as meaning
meaningful mathematics there really was
no difference between the two approaches
except for the fact that after you have
a couple of hundred years of hindsight
and can take a subject apart from a
different point of view then obviously
it's no great surprise that you can find
cleaner ways of really presenting the
topic it's the old cliche of hindsight
being better than foresight by a darn
sight or some such thing but at any rate
without further ado let's actually look
at the introduction to calculus of
several real variables from a
traditional point of view and I've
abbreviated that title to simply say
calculus of several variables whereas I
say that think of two things first of
all it's an introduction and second of
all we're going to be doing this from
the traditional point of view now what
we're assuming is remember last time we
talked about functions of several real
variables we talked about the limit
concept gave you exercises that drilled
you on what limits meant and the like
and as a result it now makes sense to
talk about the calculus the
instantaneous rate of change except that
you have an awful lot of variables in
here in other words the general case
that we'd like to tackle is the case
where we have W being some real number
being a function of the N independent
variables X 1
to X N and of course you see the
calculus applies to the F the W used
here is to indicate the fact that the
output is a real number
it's like talking about f of X versus y
equals f of X that in a manner of
speaking
it's the f of X that's important we
won't get into that right now what was
important though about y equals f of X
it indicated a graph a graph and because
it was a graph we could visualize things
pictorially that might have been harder
to understand analytically for this
reason even though n may be any positive
integer whatsoever preferably of course
greater than 1 otherwise you wouldn't
have a function of several variables but
that's the definition of a function of
several variables it's an expression of
this type where n is greater than 1 but
in general and you'll notice this in the
text as well we begin with the special
case that N equals 2 because you see if
n is 2 we need what 2 degrees of freedom
to plot the independent variables that
would be the xy-plane for example a
third degree of freedom say the z-axis
often called the W axis because of the
symbolism in other words in the same way
that I could graph a real valued
function of a single real variable as a
curve in the plane I can graph a real
valued function of two real variables as
a surface in three-dimensional space and
as a result when one is adjusting to new
language it's nice to take the case N
equals 2 simply because you can view
things pictorially the danger of course
when equals to is you get so used to the
picture that after a while you forget
that n could have been more than 2 so I
will try to pay homage to both points of
view I will simply mention here that we
will often let n equal to 2 take
advantage of geometry when we do this
the usual notation is to let W equal f
of X Y where x and y are independent and
I should mention why it's so important
to talk about independent variables that
it will become clear in a moment let me
just tell you what independent
and then I'll show you why it becomes
clear in a moment to say it x and y are
independent simply means that you can
choose one of the two variables without
determining the other for example if I
were to say let y equal 2x then
certainly Y and X are not independent
because the choice of X determines the
choice of Y but to say that x and y are
independent and that's what we mean by
two degrees of freedom is I can take any
value of x that I want and not be
impeded as to the choice of Y that I
want and that's why we say the domain is
the XY plane I have two degrees of
freedom I can roam anywhere through the
plane this way but the reason that we
want this is as follows and this is
where the traditional mathematics was
every bit as logical as the modern
mathematics let's keep in mind that
logic is the art of taking known
situations that we know how to handle
you see and reducing unfamiliar
situations to these more familiar
situations the point is that even in
traditional mathematics one knew how to
handle the calculus of a single real
variable so what one said was this given
the W is a function of both x and y
let's hold Y fixed for example and let X
vary you see if I fix Y at some
particular value and let X vary once
I've made that fixed choice of Y I have
W as a function of X alone and as long
as W is a function of X alone I already
know how to take the derivative of W
with respect to X and by the way there's
no favoritism here between x and y in a
similar way if I hold X constant and let
Y vary then W is a function of Y alone
and I can then find the derivative of W
with respect to Y and these things were
called partial derivatives you see
because it involved holding what all
about one of the variables constant will
go into that in more detail as we go
along but the whole idea is what by
choosing the variables to be independent
we can hold all of them about one at a
time constant and as long as we're doing
that the resulting function is a
function of a single real variable and
reduces us to part one of our course so
at any rate what we're saying is fix y
at some constant value say y equals y
sub 0 and we then let X vary as an
ordinary 1-dimensional calculus between
x0 minus the magnitude of Delta X and x0
plus the magnitude of Delta X in other
words we mark off an interval of
magnitude Delta X on either side of x0
and let X be any place in here then what
we do is remembering that y0 is a
constant and that this function no
matter how complicated it looks like is
a function of just Delta X alone we
mimic the definition of an ordinary
derivative in other words we take the
limit as Delta X approaches 0 of f of X
0 plus Delta X comma y0 minus f of x0
comma y0 and divide that by Delta X in
other words with y 0 being treated as a
constant notice that essentially this is
the change in F as X varies between x0
and x0 plus Delta X divided by the
change in X in other words it's the
limit of an average rate of change of f
of X with respect to X for a fixed value
of y 0 and to indicate that we write
this analogously I would say to how we
write functions of a single real
variable in other words we write f prime
is f f prime we indicate they put this
way when you had only one real variable
was there any danger of misinterpreting
the prime after all with only one
independent variable when you said
derivative it was obvious what variable
you were differentiating with respect to
here there are two variables x and y so
instead of the prime as a subscript we
write down the variable with respect to
which we're taking the derivative and
then we put in the point at which the
derivative is being evaluated you see in
a similar way to have defined f sub y of
x0 y0 that would have meant what we hold
X constant that some value x0 let Y vary
between y 0 and y 0 plus
- why and take the limit of this
expression f of x0 comma y0 + delta y
minus f of x0 y0 / delta y take the
limit of that expression as Delta Y
approaches 0 you see and we're going to
show this pictorially in a while after
all that's why we chose the case N
equals to 1 so that we can eventually
illustrate this thing pictorially but
for the time being I prefer not to
introduce the picture because I want you
to see that even in the case where my
input consists of an n-tuple where n is
greater than 2 or 3 or 4 whatever you
want that this thing still make sense in
other words in general suppose W is a
function of the N independent variables
X sub 1 up to X sub N and I want to
compute f of X sub 1 at the point X 1
equals a 1 etc xn equals a n by
definition what I do is I hold a 2 up to
a n constant I let x1 vary from a 1 to a
1 plus Delta X I compute what F of a 1
plus Delta X comma a 2 etcetera comma a
n minus F of a 1 up to a n noticing that
that numerator is simply the change in F
as x1 varies from a 1 to a 1 plus Delta
x1 while all the other variables are
being held constant which of course I
can do if the variables are independent
I then divide that by Delta x1 that's
the average rate of change then I take
the limit as Delta x1 approaches 0 and
this I can do for any number of
variables provided that they independent
keep that in mind if X sub n could be
expressed in terms of the remaining X's
how can I hold a sub n constant while or
how can I vary a sub N while I hold the
other ones constant in other words if
the ANS if if one of the variables
depends on the others they are related
in terms of their motion keep in mind
here I just chose Delta x1 analogous
definitions held for F sub X sub 2 F X
sub 3 etc okay
I think again that once you see a few
examples the mystery vanishes what this
thing says in plain English is that when
you have a function of several variables
and you want to take the derivative with
respect to one of those variables
pretend that every one of the other
variables was being held constant let me
give you an example let W be f of X 1 X
2 X 3 where the specific F that I have
in mind is obtained as follows it's X 1
times X 2 times X 3 plus e to the X 1
power now to take the derivative of this
with respect to X 1 all this says is
treat X 2 and X 3 as if they were
constants well look at if I treat X 2
and X 3 as if they were constants if I
differentiate this with respect to X 1
all I have left is what this particular
constant which is X 2 times X 3 and
derivative of e to the X 1 is with
respect to X 1 is e to the X 1 therefore
F sub X 1 in this case is X 2 X 3 plus e
to the X 1 in particular if I evaluate F
sub X sub 1 at the 3 top of 1 2 3 namely
I replace X 1 by 1 X 2 by 2 X 3 by 3 I
obtain what 2 times 3 plus e to the
first power in other words this is just
the number 6 plus e on the other hand if
I had decided to differentiate this with
respect to X 2 I would have treated X 1
and X 3 as constants with X 1 X 3 is
constants the derivative of this with
respect to X 2 is just X 1 X 3 treating
X 1 is a constant the derivative of e to
the X 1 with respect to the variable X 3
is 0 because the derivative of any
constant is 0 notice that this is not
really a constant it's a constant once
our fixed X 1 of the particular value
which is what this particular definition
says in particular F sub X sub 2 of 1 2
3 is 1 times 3 or 3 I should also
mention that sometimes instead of
writing f of X sub 1 we write something
that looks like the regular derivative
only we make a funny kind of square
d instead of an ordinary D this has read
the partial derivative of W with respect
to X 1 and the relationship between
these two notations is rather similar to
the relationship that exists between the
notations dy/dx and F prime of X at any
rate if we have the n independent
variables X 1 up to xn and F is a
function of those variables F sub X sub
1 etc F sub X sub n are called the
partial derivatives of F with respect to
X 1 up to xn respectively in other words
this means what the partial derivative
of F with respect to X 1 that means what
take the ordinary derivative as if X 1
were the only variable this is the
partial of F with respect to X sub n
that means take the ordinary derivative
of F as if X sub n were the only
variable and you can always do this
provided that your variables are
independent because our definitions so
closely parallel the structure for what
happened in the case of one independent
variable including the limit theorems
the distance formulas and what have you
it turns out that the usual derivative
properties still hold for example if W
happens to be the function of the two
independent variables e to the 3x plus y
times sine 2x minus y and I want to take
the derivative of W with respect to X
meaning differentiate this treating Y as
a constant
notice that treating Y as a constant
gives me two functions of what X in
other words I my function is a product
of two functions each of which depends
on X so I use the ordinary product rule
to differentiate this namely how do I
use the product rule to take the partial
of W respect to X I treat Y is a
constant and I differentiate as if X is
the only variable I say what it's the
first factor e to the 3x plus y times
the derivative of the second with
respect to X treating Y as a constant
if I treat Y is a constant the
derivative of sine of 2x minus y is
cosine 2x minus y times the derivative
of what
inside with respect to X and that's just
2 plus what the second term times the
derivative of the first and the
derivative of e to the 3x plus y with
respect to X treating Y as a constant is
e to the 3x plus y times the derivative
of 3x plus y with respect to X which is
just 3 and so I have the partial of W
with respect to X in a similar way I
could have found the partial of W with
respect to Y etc I should now introduce
one little problem that will bother you
maybe even after I help you with this in
fact I guess what really crushes me is
the student who comes up in a live class
know after class and says I understood
it until I heard you lecture on it I
hope this doesn't cause that problem but
the danger is I tell you look at
everything that happened for calculus of
a single variable happens for calculus
of several variables then all of a
sudden you'll find an art textbook and
every textbook just about they'll say
things like look it if you take the
partial of the variable U with respect
to X you do not get the reciprocal of
the partial of X with respect to you in
other words remember for one variable
dy/dx right was the reciprocal of DX dy
they say it's not true in several
variables I have written in an
accentuated question mark here because I
want to explain something very important
to you and by the way if you understand
this you're 90% of the way home free as
far as understanding how calculus of
several variables is used in most
important applications let me take a
very simple case let u equal X plus y
and let V equal X minus y now obviously
if u equals x plus y the partial of U
with respect to X if we hold Y constant
with read X is the only variable is 1
right the partial of U with respect to X
is 1 on the other hand notice that if I
add these two equations the Y term drops
out I get what 2x equals u plus V divide
through by 2 that says X is equal to 1/2
u plus 1/2 V
let me now take the partial of X with
respect to you holding V constant
treating you is the only variable it's
easy for me to see that the partial of X
with respect to you is 1/2 and certainly
if I now compare these two it should be
clear that this is not the reciprocal of
this or vice versa the point that I
wanted to mention though was the
following that when here we said take
the partial of U with respect to X we
were assuming that the independent
variables were x and y and when we said
here take the partial of X with respect
to u what did we hold constant we held
the constant in other words I'm not
going to keep this habit up very long
but just for the time being I would like
you to get used to the idea of putting
in as a subscript the variables that are
being held constant you see in the
textbook when they say this is the case
what they really mean is if you
differentiate u with respect to X
holding Y constant that in general will
not be the reciprocal of the derivative
of X with respect to u holding V
constant so I can cross out the question
mark now but the point is notice that
the variables that you're holding
constant here are different you see
suppose instead I took the partial of X
with respect to u holding Y constant in
other words suppose I solve for X in
terms of U and Y that happens to be very
easy to do here if given that u equals x
plus y it follows a mealy that X is
equal to u minus y now if I take the
partial of X with respect to u treating
Y is a constant so let me do that what
do I get for an answer I get 1 for an
answer in other words the reciprocal of
the partial of X with respect to u
treating Y is a constant as the other
independent variable is equal to the
partial of U with respect to X when it's
also why that's being considered as the
other variable when the variables
outside here match up the recipes work
because that leads to the question then
why do the textbooks tell you that this
isn't true why do they pick this
particular representation rather than
this one and I have a combination
example an explanation here and it's
simply this let's suppose I was given
that w equals e to the X plus y times
cosine X minus y it seems that since the
only way the variable appears in the
first factor is as X plus y and the only
way it appears in the second factor is
in the form X minus y a very natural
substitution might be to say let u equal
X plus y and V equal X minus y in other
words I could eat either visualize W as
being a function of x and y in which
case it would be e to the X plus y times
cosine X minus y or I could visualize W
as being a simpler function of the two
new variables U and V where W is then
just what e to the U times cosine V
notice again that this formula here is
much simpler than this one this one says
what take e to the sum of these two
multiplied by the cosine of the
difference of these two and this one
just says what take e to the first times
the cosine of the second but the point
is that you might make this change of
variables to simplify your computations
the point is that either we would treat
W as a function of x and y or we would
have treated w as a function of U and V
and by the way notice here my use of F
and G notice that f is a that W is a
different function of x and y than it is
of U and V but this notation says what
we can consider W either in terms of X
and y or in terms of U and V hardly ever
would we consider W as a function of U
and Y in other words either we would
change the variables or we don't oh for
example in terms of polar versus
Cartesian coordinates either we use X
and Y or we use our and theta we don't
usually use R and X notice going back to
the textbook example again if we look at
this particular situation here all the
book is saying is look at when you're
differentiating what we
expect 2x you usually mean that why is
the variable being held constant we
differentiate with respect to you you
usually mean that V is the variable
that's being held constant again more of
this is said in our exercises but for
the time being I want you to see how
important it is when you have several
variables to keep track of which are the
dependent variables which are the
independent variables and how they're
coupled I said earlier that one of the
nice things about picking N equals two
is that you can draw a nice picture of a
situation and when I thought you might
like to see is the following let's
suppose you have the W is some function
of x and y what that means is we can
locate for a given value of x and a
given value of y in other words for x
equals x 0 y equals y 0 we can think of
the point x 0 y 0 as being in the
xy-plane w which is f of x 0 y 0 is just
the height to this particular surface in
other words if i let f of x0 y0 be
called w 0 notice that the function f of
x y at the point x equals x 0 y equals y
0 graphically corresponds to the point
whose coordinates are x 0 y 0 and w 0 ok
this is now a surface and in the same
way that we use tangent lines to replace
curves when we had one independent
variable in two independent variables we
use tangent planes to in to replace
surfaces the question that comes up is
how do you get a tangent plane and what
does this have to do with the partial
derivatives and what I'd like to show
you is the following first of all one
very natural way of intersecting this
surface with a plane in other words when
you take the partial of W with respect
to Y you're holding X constant you're
saying Let X equal X 0 notice that in
three-dimensional space x equals x 0 is
the equation of this plane and this
plane see what is the plane x equals x 0
it's the plane that goes through the
line x equal
x0 parallel to the W Y plane this plane
intersects my surface in a particular
curve that curve passes through p0 I can
talk about the slope of the curve at
that particular point okay in a similar
way I could have sliced the surface by a
plane y equals y 0 in other words hold Y
constant where you see to hold Y
constant that means I again draw my
plane it intersects the surface in a
different curve but that curve must also
go through the point p0 that's the same
p0 but it's over here because after all
the point on the surface that is
directly above x0 y0 is p 0 and that
point doesn't change no matter what
plane you slice this thing with okay and
so again I can talk about the slope of
the tangent to this particular curve of
intersection by the way one very brief
aside before I continue on with this one
of the things that makes functions of
several variables so difficult is I
would like you to observe because this
will become the backbone of our future
investigations that these two particular
planes that I drew to intersect my
surface were very special planes one of
them was parable they both went through
the point x0 y0 but one happened to be
parallel to the W Y plane and the other
one happened to be parallel to the W X
plane notice that in general I could
have passed infinitely many different
planes through x0 y0 each of which would
have intersected the surface at a in a
different curve and this is what leads
later to the more generalized concept of
directional derivatives that we will
talk about in more detail in our future
lectures but I simply mention the word
now because in the reading material in
this assignment some mention is made of
directional derivatives in other words I
want to point out that to take partial
derivatives we are interested in two
special directions even
there are other directions the question
that comes up of course is where do the
partials come in here and secondly
knowing where the partials come up in
here where do they use how do we find
the equation of a tangent plane and all
I would like you to see from here is
that I'm going to use the same old
technique as always given these two
tangent lines I am going to vectorize
them I am then going to find the
equation of the plane that passes
through those two vectors to do that I'm
going to have to find the normal to that
plane etc and I'm going to wind up with
the equation of a tangent plane in more
slow motion all I'm saying is if I now
take this picture and draw it over here
notice the representation it looks as if
the curve that I get is in the W Y plane
it's actually in a plane parallel to the
W Y plane characterized by x equals x
sub 0 and by the way notice even though
x equals x0 was chosen so that x0 was
fixed I hope it's clear to you that if I
let X sub 0 vary and I pick different
values of x sub 0 the curve that I get
here will in general differ you see what
I'm saying is if I take slices parallel
to the W Y plane for a particular
surface the slices that I get the shape
will depend on what the particular value
of x0 is but that's not the crucial
issue right now the point that I'm
driving at is if I now call this tangent
if I better eyes the tangent line and
call that v1 what does that tangent line
look like first of all let's see what
its slope is now again if you didn't see
this over here and all I showed you was
this diagram you would say hey that
slope is just the derivative of W with
respect to Y but we write that the
partial of W with respect to Y in
deference to the fact that W is not a
function of Y alone that W depends on
both X and Y and the reason that we got
this curve was that we fixed X at some
particular value so this is really what
not the putt not the derivative of W
with respect to Y evaluated at y equals
wise
it's the partial of W with respect to Y
evaluated at what x0 comma y0 all right
at any rate now that we have the slope
notice that the slope of the vector can
always be viewed as the K component in
this case the K component divided by the
J component if I make the J component 1
the slope will just be the K component
in other words a vector which is tangent
to the curve and one that's easy to
write down is J plus the partial of W
with respect to Y evaluated at x0 y0
times k and notice by the way that this
is a number that once I take the partial
derivative and evaluated at a point I
have a number so this is what a constant
vector once x0 and y0 are fixed in a
similar way my vector v2 which is for my
curve parallel to the WX plane the slope
of that curve at the point p0 is not the
W DX it's the partial of W with respect
to X evaluated at x0 y0 again why
because double even though this looks
like W is a function of X alone here it
was only that way because we took the
second variable and in a sense froze it
at the value y 0 at any rate in an
analogous manner v2 turns out to be what
vector its I plus the partial of W with
respect to X evaluated at x0 y0 times K
in other words the slope is the partial
of W with respect to X and it's in the I
cape lane in other words the X W plane
now that I have my two vectors to find
the plane that passes through them all I
need is what the normal vector and a
point in the plane well one of the nice
things about having studied Cartesian
loop the cross-product here is that I
can now take the cross product of v1 and
v2 sparing you the details
remember what I do here I just write
down i JK v1 has these components v2 has
these components I now expand this
determinant in the usual way
and I get what this particular vector in
other words the I component is the
partial of W with respect to X the J
component is the partial of W with
respect to Y both evaluated at the point
x0 y0 and the K component is minus 1 now
to find the equation of the tangent
plane all I have to do is what take the
standard form of the plane in other
words the coefficients will be these and
then I take X 0 y 0 W 0 which is a point
in my plane and then the equation of the
tangent plane becomes quite simply this
expression here and in fact if I rewrite
that notice I can transpose the W minus
W 0 term that is the change in W but to
remind us that we're in a tangent plane
we don't write this as Delta W we write
it as Delta W sub 10 and notice that the
change in W 2 the tangent plane is just
the partial of W with respect to X times
Delta X plus the partial of W with
respect to Y times Delta Y and hopefully
this starts to seem familiar to you
this should almost look like the
equation of delta y-tan only in two
dimensions member we had delta y-tan and
part 1 of the course see what this
really says is what this is the change
in W with respect to X multiplied by the
total change in X in other words this
term is what it's the change in W due to
the change in X alone this term is the
change in W with respect to Y times the
total change in Y so this term tells you
the change in W due to the change in Y
alone and if you add these two up since
x and y are independent this should give
you the total change in W the reason of
course that you don't get the total
change in W but rather Delta W 10 is the
fact that if you if these expressions
here are not constant numbers as Delta X
and Delta Y are varying these numbers
here are varying these are variables but
you see once you fix these at these
values these become numbers and now you
know what Delta W tan is now look at in
some of the homework problems in the
text what we're going to do is
practice the geometry itself we're going
to find equations of tangent planes the
thing that's very important to us in
future lectures from a structural point
of view is that the equation of the
tangent plane in other words the
equation for Delta W 10 is far more
simple to handle than the equation for
the true Delta W you see the equation
for Delta W tan just has Delta X and
Delta Y appearing to the first power
whereas if you try to find Delta W
exactly for an arbitrary function of x
and y this can become a very very messy
thing in short Delta W 10 will play for
two and more independent variables the
same role that Delta Y sub 10 played for
us in part 1 of this course as a
differential and what we'll be
discussing next or at least trying to
get at the root of is just what does
play the role of a differential when
you're dealing with calculus of several
variables and what we're going to find
is that again the computations become
messy enough so even though the
structure stays fairly nice there are
some wrinkles that come up that will
take us a considerable amount of time to
untangle but we're worried about that
when the time comes and so until that
time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate